what's going on guys national master
james canton iii here with chess.com and
today
we have game of the day with the white
pieces we have stock fish and with the
black pieces
leela chess zero let's get right into it
guys it's a very exciting game
we have e4 e5 knight f3 and knight to c6
and then who doesn't love a roy lopez
guy especially to b5
classical games you get classical stuff
or sometimes even better when you watch
these engines play
knight of six in berlin fashion and we
have d3 here to defend
the pawn one of the most solid ways to
play not only does it lock the bishop
outside the pawn chain temporarily
maybe we might back it up sometimes in
the classical roy lopez's and stay on
this long diagonal to be able to play d4
after we play c3 and at the same time it
also uh develops our bishop or
gives us a scope for the bishop that we
would love to use so after d3 bishop to
c5 from black just saying hey
if you're not going to play c3 if you're
not going to take over the d4 square
i'm going to take over the d4 square
also put my bishop on a very nice square
here
and also put some pressure on the f2
square just a soft point for for white
so after bishop to c5 we have bishop
takes c6
and then we have d take c6 now a lot of
times guys you should take
take towards the center is the rule
actually you want to capture towards the
center but in this case actually this
pawn
could be hanging on e5 now let me ask
you this guys if d
takes c6 like what happened in the game
would you take the pawn on e5
is that a yes or no from you would you
take the pawn on e5
this right here knight takes c5 would
you make this move for y
the answer here is actually whatever you
want it to be if you're going to say yes
okay you can take the pawn but is it the
right answer actually
is the question here knight takes c5
this is not the right move guys we
briefly looking at it knight takes c5
just because there's a pawn that you can
capture
does not mean you should actually always
take it you need to look for checks and
captures
what would they actually do if you take
this pawn here and if knight takes c5
there's queen to d4 and this is already
over guys this is already over queen
queen d4 is attacking checkmate on f2
and also
a double attack with the knight here so
no matter where you go if you go knight
to g4 i'm just going to take uh
remove the defender with maybe bishop
takes or knight takes g4 followed by
crashing down on f2 with checkmate so no
problem there guys you can't take on and
on e5 so actually the engine of course
didn't take on e5
and played castle getting out of the way
now this pawn is actually hanging
and we actually defend it with queen e7
from lila chess
then we have knight b to d2 here guys we
have to develop looking at this position
you also had moves like bishop to g5
which is more a human-like move knight
c3 as well but i do like
knight b to d2 a lot because these
knights are very nice
um and they they just cover each other
just in case of course when the bishop
comes to g4 which is slightly annoying
that's exactly what happened to as well
it's bishop to g4
so you have some a friend here that can
help you unless you
move it the next move right here right
to c4 attacking the pawn on e5 actually
and also in some cases playing stuff
like bishop to e3 and after bishop takes
you can actually take back with the
knight
to be able to attack this bishop just a
little bit more because a lot of times
if this pin happens guys
you can't untangle sometimes and you
find yourself as a human
playing stuff like h3 and g4 when you
have to open up the king side that's not
always recommended sometimes they even
sacrifice and you find yourself
in a very bad position but the knight
was covering here but
stockfish has other ideas knight to c4
and then after knight to d7 defending
the pawn
we have h3 indeed trying to kick the
bishop away
ax the bishop what are you going to do
of course we're going to back up and
keep the pressure here bishop h5
and then we have interesting move here
guys what would you actually play here
with the white pieces
take a moment and look around the board
pause the video if you need to
what would you play here is why
the answer actually uh from stockfish is
bishop to d2 guys now i think bishop e3
could have been played as well
and uh maybe even stuff like maybe c3
rookie one but these are kind of slower
moves i really like bishop d2 or bishop
e3
just because you have to develop guys
you got to get the pieces off the back
ring
and bishop d2 actually has a dual
purpose move with it
not only does it develop but it also
maybe has some attacking chances on this
side
or helping us push pawns on this side of
the board let's keep watching the video
and after f6 a4 so here's a4 we're
stopping b5 not only stopping b5 but
maybe
a5 a6 so if he tries to castle queen
side which seems absolutely ridiculous
maybe he'll be in trouble and we'll
already be ready right a4 and then
knight to f8
interesting move wants to put the knight
on just a better square here if you go
back and look at where the knight was
the knight had no good squares this is a
gross knight i mean it literally has
nowhere to move
except the b6 square which really
doesn't do anything at this point so
knight f8
very very nice strategical move here
actually knight of fate and then b4 guys
whoa
wild move from stockfish here just plays
b4
would you expect it and a lot of times
you want to make these kind of moves um
with your opponent to make the
unexpected
kind of moves and see if they actually
work here now if bishop takes b4 were to
happen guys what would you actually play
this is not the game move but what would
you play in bishop takes b4 what is the
intention of this b4
giving up this move here now i will tell
you the human version of it or most
people would do bishop takes
queen takes followed by rook to b1 and
then taking on b7
that's what probably would happen but
actually
and that's what i looked at too i was
like just take and play rook b1 maybe
but actually the best move was queen to
b1 in this position and after queen b1
it actually attacks the b7 pawn and if
bishop takes him we do queen takes b7
hitting the rook and the c6 pawn at the
same time
and the bishop is hanging all at the
same moment guys we would have moved
there
queen b1 was super cool but in the game
actually leela chess was like i'm not
gonna do that
and play bishop d6 and just backed up
now of course at this point this bishop
is now what we call a big pawn
because it can't do anything it's not
doing anything it looks just like
one of the pawns so after bishop to d6
we just put a little bit of pressure on
the file while also defending
the b-pawn rook to b1 and knight to e6
from leela chess
as we're just going to get that piece
into game into the game we move to f8 we
don't want to keep it there same thing
if you keep a knight on the rim
you want to get him back into the center
as quickly as possible we moved it to e6
and then we have knight to a5 here
attacking the b7
pawn interesting right how do you defend
it
how do you defend it maybe like rick b8
right rook b8 seems sensible
seems like a move to make but here's
what leela chest did guys
here's what leela chest zero did castle
queenside
wow why would you castle
to this side of war now i always tell my
students things like this all the time
you always need to question the engine
always just question it sometimes
they may seem like they're wrong of
course the engine knows all but at this
in this kind of case guys who would
castle
to this side of the board because of
everything going on
it seems like you're so much safer to
castle to this side of the board right
but actually lelich has zero said i
don't care i'm leela chad zero and
castle queen side here
and let's see what happens next guys
this is very good this is gonna be very
fun
so if i'm playing white here what would
you actually play castle queenside it's
your move
they just castled you have a rook on a b
file a knight on a5 ready to go
what are you going to do here
white to move here it is b5 b5 open it
up
open it up and it was like huh we're not
opening anything look at this bishop
guys
worst piece on the board right looks
really bad here and here we go stockfish
makes a nasty move here
knight to c6 okay we're forking the
queen and the rook at the same time
and then b takes c6 and then b takes c6
and now we have to do something so
black's like well let's figure out what
we do i mean
we need to get away somehow you know
let's see what happens and here it is
after bishop to g6 guys
after bishop to g6 white
to move i hope you had your tactics
today i hope you had your tactics for
breakfast
i hope you do your tactics every day
it's right to move
you finish it off what do you do here
white to move guys
stock fish played here it is rook v8
check
wow wow look for checks and captures
guys look for checks and captures first
the moves that you don't consider are
sometimes
the moves that win the game on the spot
rick b a check
king takes queen b1 check and no matter
what you do
check mate next move king a8 and queen
b7 check
mate beautiful way to mate and it
happened literally
seconds after castle's queen side guys
this is why
you should never castle into the attack
where are the pieces aiming at
probably don't want to castle to that
side now of course
these are engines playing but it was
just nice to see guys b5
c5 knight c6 beautiful way to finish
this off and if you move the rook then
i'm going to take the queen you take the
you move the queen i take the rook very
simple
so after takes um takes takes bishop g6
i mean there's really no way to get out
of it actually here
either but uh bishop g6 rick b8 takes
and check
and checkmate guys wild game i hope you
enjoyed it guys this was game of the day
i'm national master james canty iii with
chess.com and i'll see you guys
on the next video